what a crybaby Harold I'm just gonna
spit this out I sold a little product to
the cartels but when we cut them off
they got a little angry how there's a
guy working in middle management at a
pharmaceutical company that is run by
Richard and Elaine I apply Richard Rusk
who's sort of everything you love to
hate about corporate America
Harold played by David olor is the
opposite of Richard he's everything you
love about humanity kind generous and
he's the center of the story so I should
buy mine of his misery so we should
literally so original and it's really so
rare that something is original I mean
come on
tomorrow you can apply to Mexico what he
does these runs down to Mexico once a
month to do inventory but what he's not
aware of is that the company at which
he's hoping to progress through the
ranks is about to be sold what do they
want you got again I'm not really
Buckley I know a guy I'll track down a
dictators I can find a guy in middle
management which is an injectable
microchip I need to keep track
I thought the idea felt very real if it
was played straight it would still have
humor and be entertaining things you can
just hope to get better for you if he is
through a pretty unbelievable
set of circumstances all of which add up
to him being I think the better and I'm
not supposed to touch the minibar but
I'm going to do it you know I don't even
care anymore I'm doing it
[Music]
you